en cas de piqûre de méduse que vous
voulez savoir c'est est-ce que vous êtes
vraiment obligé de courir sur la plage
en hurlant s'il vous
vous plaît à part en cas d'infection
urinaire le pipi c'est stérile du coup
c'est vrai que c'est tentant bah oui
mais non non parce qu'en réalité quand
la piqûre de méduse vous gratte ou vous
pique il y a qu'une petite partie des
nématocytes présentes sur votre peau qui
ont déjà injecté leur venin l'idée c'est
d'empêcher les autres de le faire et
l'urine comme l'eau douce ça risque de
les exciter et de déclencher l'injection
de leurs cochonneries le mieux à faire
c'est d'abord de sortir de l'eau pour
pas se noyer en cas de malaise ensuite
de ne pas gratter la zone de retourner
l'avancée à l'eau de mer sans frotter de
revenir sur la plage et de coller dessus
une bonne dose de sable chaud puis
d'attendre un peu et de retirer le sable
et toutes ces saletés de cellules en
raclant avec un bout de carton ou une
carte de crédit ensuite mettez de
l'antiseptique dessus et aller voir
votre formation qui vous donnera ce
qu'il faut pour calmer la douleur vous
pouvez aussi tremper l'endroit où vous
avez été piqué dans l'eau chaude pendant
une vingtaine de minutes si vous
ressentez ce qu'on appelle des signes
généraux c'est-à-dire pas juste
localiser au niveau de la piqûre allez
voir votre médecin surtout si vous avez
déjà été piqué plusieurs fois